we begin this morning with the growing
wild fire danger in northern and
southern California in Sonoma and Lake
counties north of San Francisco hundreds
of residents were forced to flee to
safety late Friday as wind driven flames
burned through that dry terrain with
historic winds on the way the state's
largest utility company is considering
another run of intentional power outages
as a means of preventing the Kinkaid
fire from spreading in Southern
California
firefighters have contained about 10% of
the ticke fire Janet shamlian is in
Santa Clarita about 35 miles north of
Los Angeles Janet good morning Jeff good
morning to you thousands of people
remain evacuated from their homes this
morning including in this neighborhood
were embers from a small brush fire in
the hills nearby were carried here
yesterday by those gusting winds and
torch this home but it's what's ahead
forecasters are saying that could be far
worse more than 4,000 acres consumed and
at least 40,000 residents forced to
leave their homes the wind-driven tick
fires burning through canyons and
neighborhoods in Santa Clarita yeah be
physically ready you have to have all
your your things ready to leave you know
this time of year Kevin Kinney watched
his neighbor's house destroyed by flames
so that missed you by two houses yeah at
least six homes have been consumed by
the fire seven others have been damaged
I'm overwhelmed depressed David chambers
obeyed evacuation orders returning to
find an upstairs window shattered by an
explosive water drop a huge blast so but
again it saved the house the worst is
still ahead forecasters say Dugger
predictions for an historic wind event
Sunday and Monday with gusts up to 80
miles an hour in Northern California
where the larger scale Kincaid fire has
placed entire counties under a thick
veil of smoke we are preparing for what
is likely going to be a widespread
safety shutoff the state's largest
utility PG&E warned it may cut
electricity for a third time in three
weeks ahead the worsening conditions
potentially leaving millions without
power the utility
investigating whether the fire was
sparked by a transmission tower that had
not been de-energized
they simply did not do their job
California Governor Gavin Newsom was
critical of the company you should not
have to be here years and years of greed
we will get out of this mess we will
hold them to an account that they have
never been held in the past back in
Santa Clarita some residents have made
their way home I want to sleep I want to
be with my animals
I believe they lifted the evacuation
notice then you know hopefully they'll
open the roads pretty soon so PG&E will
decide today on cutting off power to two
million people in Northern California
that would be a historic power shut off
but this storm that's supposed to come
in this windstorm is also being called
historic and extreme and the problem
with it Michelle is that it's going to
last for many hours rush time out there
for a lot of Californians Shannon thank
you